hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the fidi World Cup we are in the
first game of the classical time format
it is pregnant versus Magnus Carlsen and
for the occasion I even used their
updated ratings these are the live
ratings so uh before the game Prague was
a 27 23.4 in the Magnuson 28 42.6 so
quite a bit of a difference but if frog
wants to win he has to do it against one
of the if not the greatest player of all
times the Magnus Carlsen and uh well
we've had the appetizer the game between
Fabiano Corona that definitely got us
going and now it's time for the main
course uh Prague has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to C4 he opts for
the English opening and Magnus did not
arrive late he arrived basically two
seconds before the clocks were started
he you know offered a handshake and then
he took quite some time to make the
first move you know he always has that
ritual he first you know uh sets up
every beats piece perfectly in the
center of the square and then he writes
everything down then he looks at the
board and only then did he proceed to
play Pawn to E5 and okay we have the
English end as every time we have in
English we will have the Four Knights of
the English Knight C3 Knight to F6
Knight to F3 and Knight the C6 progress
for Pawn to G3 uh and pawn to D5 by
Magnus with C captures Knight captures
and now Bishop to G2 so fairly standard
stuff Knight back to F6 Magnus goes for
um uh well a bit of a different line
usually Bishop to C5 is played uh and uh
now he basically brings his piece back
which he kind of breaks the chess
principle do not move the same piece
twice in the opening but of course he
knows what he's doing and it has been
played before usually people just
um uh Castle here or play Ponte A3 but
Prague goes for Pawn to B4 and I love
seeing Ponto B4 I love seeing it in
every position I've never seen it in a
position fight like this before and you
can't really uh capture it of course
you're not gonna capture it with the
Knight because nothing is Defending Your
E5 Pawn if you do that and of course if
you play Bishop characters on B4 then
again Knight captures on E5 you just
remove the defender of the bishop here
and if Knight captures an E5 Queen to A4
comes with the check okay you block with
Knight to C6 you again defend the bishop
but now Bishop captures and C6 with
check B captures uh and now Queen
captures and B4 prevents the black king
from castling uh White is doing very
well here so obviously Magnus will not
be capturing the B4 Pawn but that also
means that then he has to be worried
about Pawn to B5 and dislodging the
knight from C6 so what can he do about
this well he goes for Bishop to D6 he
just adds another Defender to the E5
pawn and okay Pro goes Pawn to B5 Knight
to D4 and now we have Queen the A4 proc
took a little bit of time to go for this
but not too much it was Magnus who was
burning a lot of time in the opening for
the first three moves uh for the first
couple of moose Prague basically plated
everything within a minute and Magnus
already spent some 20 minutes on the
clock and here there are quite a few
lines you could go choose from one very
interesting one is Pawn to C5 I'm just
gonna show it because it's a lot of fun
Pawn captures Knight goes back with
captors and now Knights to B5 going
after the bishop here and you might
think all right I mean the queen is
already defending the bishop not a
problem I'll just Castle here and
already you blunder the game Knight
characters Queen characters and Bishop
to A3 with a beautiful skewer here so
you have to be careful Magnus plays the
absolute best move Knight captures on F3
with check with of Bishop characters and
now Castles by both players castles
castles with Pawn to A6 now of course
this is never an idea because the Rook
on A8 is undefended but the bishop will
get developed at some point with Bishop
to D3 opting for Bishop to G5 and here
uh what do you play it's such a such a
fine position now uh here H6 was played
obviously you do not want to see Bishop
to G5 on the board but now what's uh
what do you play next uh again so many
so many possibilities here do you go for
uh do you go for something like Bishop
to A3 this is what Prague went for I'm
just going to show you a really fun line
with Rook to B1 as its classical chess
so we should explore a couple of lines
look at this queen to E7 now Bishop to
E3 and Bishop to D7 not allowing the
pawn to capture on E6 or anything Queen
back the C2 now comes eight captures on
B5 Knight captures on B5 and now this
very tricky Pawn to e for move so uh the
idea is of course bringing the bishop to
C6 and now if Bishop captures an E4
you're just gonna to capture an E4 the
counters Bishop to C6 and you are very
very happy with your position here white
does not have a light Square Bishop you
do have a light Square Bishop if this
diagonal fully opens up white will have
um uh well quite a lot to worry about F3
will have to be played but that will
also give white a very tricky position
to handle but okay instead after the
spawn to H6 we have Bishop to A3
offering to trade of the dark Square
Bishops uh the dark Square Bishops and
now comes Rook to B8 by Magnus here he
also spent quite a lot of time because
if you can pull off Bishop to D7 or
Bishop to H3 then it should be uh well
it should be a great position for black
the problem is Bishop to H3 is almost
impossible to calculate magnets really
tried but just to give you an example
Bishop captures on B7 and now let's say
you go for eight characters on B5 you
attack the White Queen here you're gonna
play Queen captures an A8 Queen captures
an A8 now comes Bishop capture 78 and
Bishop capture is on F1 Bishop captures
on B6 would check C captures sorry C
captures and now King captures on F1 on
the B4 chases away the Knight Knights
the D5 and The Rook captures an A8 with
Knight captures on B4 and after this
capture Fest is over uh it will be
Prague who will be up upon and it will
be the past a pawn so not the absolute
best however there is one other thing
you could try after Bishop to H3 after
Bishop captures on B7 let's not go for
eight characters on B5 let's go for
Bishop captures and F1 instead so Bishop
captures an F1 Rook captures an F1 and
only now a captures on B5 Queen captures
an A8 Queen captures Bishop captures and
now Rook captures an A8 Bishop captures
on D6 C captures on D6 and you end up
with the disposition where yeah okay you
could uh let's say capture on B5 but if
you capture on B5 then Rook captures an
A2 Knight captures on D6 and The Rook
captures an E2 you again end up with a
position where it's equal material but
magnet this okay he does have the intact
Pawn structure proc has the isolated
d-pawn you know it's not much to work
with uh so that doesn't really do all
that much for him so Bishop to H3
definitely a possibility but it doesn't
uh it doesn't yield all that much Bishop
to D7 on the other hand uh could be
played many different ways but uh well
we want to throw in this a captures on
B5 move in pretty much all of the lines
even if you start with Bishop captures
and uh at D6 it now comes a captures on
B5 going after the White Queen here and
now you're first gonna throw in a nice
solution to Bishop captures on C7 twin
characters on C7 and now Queen to B3 or
queen to B4 uh we end up with um well
it's equal material but Magnus would
have a double B Pawn but it still looks
very very strong especially with the
bishop controlling the the A4 Square you
can never get A4 in everything controls
it uh also looks uh I mean it looks very
nice uh so you could play it but Magnus
doesn't like either of this as a
commentators thought that maybe it's
because it was too dry should Magnus
wanted something more so he opted for
Rook to B8 and okay Bishop to D7 uh
sorry uh First bishop captures on D6 C
captures and now Rook a to B1 and now a
captures on B5 okay Queen captures on B5
and now Bishop to D7 so proc does have
very uh uh a very good pressure against
the B7 Pawn but he first has the 10 to
the queen queen to B6 and now Magnus
finds a move that solves all of his
problems and that is Bishop to C6 uh
problem being a tactical one
uh if procapters in C6 okay you can play
this but then Queen captures and C6 is
met with Rook C8 and you blunder the
Knight on C3 so this is out of the
question Queen captures and d8 is what
product plays we have Rook f chapter 78
and only now Bishop captures on C6 we
have B captures and C6 and now you could
choose from a lot of moves like A4 is a
more Rook character Sun V8 is a move uh
yeah you could start with Pont F4 one
therefore is actually very nice for
example he captures you trade Rooks
captures captures and now you take an F4
with the Rook let's say Pawn to D5 and
um it's a nice position for Prague he
always has the past a pawn that he can
push but Magnus has the center and he
will also be able to create a pass Pawn
at some point but instead after Bishop
captures on C6 proc just goes King to G2
no not rushing it uh in any way now
Magnus shifts the attention over to the
Past a pawn we have Rook to B6 now
Prague goes after the C6 spawn and the
Magnus has a couple of ways of dealing
with this he could go Knight to the D5
it's a very nice idea where you could uh
double black spawns here or you could
just trade everything Rook captures
Knight captures Rook captures on C3 and
Rook captures an A2 and you end up with
the exact same position pretty much uh
almost even the same Pawn structure this
would of course be a drawn position so
Rook D to C8 Magnus wants to keep
chances alive he just defends the pawn
and now Rook the C1 we have Pawn to D5
and now Rook the C2 guarding the A2 Pawn
uh we have Knights the D7 attacking the
rook and now Rook back to B1 we have
Knights the C5 and now we have Rook B to
C1 doubling up on the C file now the
Knight will move and you will put a lot
of pressure on the C file so Rook to A5
and now Knight to B1 threatening to
capture the Knight here yeah but Magnus
uh of course calculated everything
Knight D6 and now you could go for an
all-out trade The Rook captures on C6
Rook captures Rook captures we have Rook
captures on A2 Knight to C3 and now Rook
the C2 we have Knight captures on D5
Rook captures on E2 and okay again you
have the pretty much the exact same
position that we already reached from
that position but EU can even go for
further trades Knight E3 let's say
rookie do you go after the pawn Knight
C4 goes after the five Pawn captures
captures attacks The Rook Rook moves and
uh uh okay I mean the uh three pawns on
uh on the same size of the side of the
board of course it's a dead draw so
after this Knight the detail was played
we have Rook C to A8 Magnus doubles up
on the a file Knight to F3 and now Pawn
to E4 this is how Magnus wants to keep
chances alive captures captures sorry
captures captures attacks the Knight
Knight the D2 and now of course even
Ponte E3 sacrifices upon the mess of a
Prague spawn structure but prog doesn't
go for it he just goes Knight C4 attacks
the rook and will capture an E3 with the
Knight so Rook captures an A2 Knight
captures on E3 we have Knights to D4 now
attacking the rook and just Rook
captures an eighth two with Rook
captures on A2 Rook to C4 now goes after
the Knight and Magnus offers a draw by
uh you know at uh basically by by saying
a joke he plays upon the C5 uh it's a
draw for if Prague captures of course he
captures an E2 and that's it so real
captures on C5 was played Rook captures
on E2 and he was in this position on
move 35 that Prague and Magnus agreed to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here pretty a completely equal
position three pawns on the same side of
the board Knight and a knight and rook
and there's no point in playing this
both of them had enough time on the
clock and when you're this good then
this is basically a draw by insufficient
material so uh a very nice game it uh
you know definitely looked like a Magnus
couldn't do anything and the Prague was
the one running the show but Prague had
the white pieces in this game and as
soon as Magnus equalized there was
really nothing to hope for anymore so
now Magnus will have the white pieces
and it's it's a question will prog be
able to equalize uh as quickly as Magnus
did or uh you know maybe he will even be
able to go for something it's hard to
say uh or was this prague's idea all
along does he wanna uh is the idea to
draw the the classical games and then
look for chances in faster time formats
or uh was this just a case of you know
excellent preparation uh being met with
excellent preparation so it's uh hard to
say I'm just here to enjoy the show and
um you know hoping you guys are as well
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it we'll see what happens
in round two of the classical this was
uh wonderful to watch uh I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Brahm and
I would like to thank Wives and Lovers
Robert Bloom at girls in
chessfestival.org.gg and film maltas for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the video World Cup finals
until it finishes uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and what do you think
what will Magnus open with uh with the
white pieces in tomorrow's game uh see
you soon